bonsoir un nouveau numéro du 7-8
politique chaque mois nous revenons sur
les dossiers de l'actualité avec nous
inviter je recevrai tout à l'heure le
maire de magny les hameaux le socialiste
bertrand ou lyon pour évoquer la
fermeture prochaine du centre pmi de sa
commune et son conflit sur ce dossier
avec le conseil départemental
une manifestation vient d'avoir lieu en
ce 9 février vous le voyez nous
parlerons aussi du regard qu'il porte
sur la situation de tensions entre
majorité et opposition au sein du
nouveau saint quentin en yvelines de la
nouvelle agglomération pour le moment
j'accueille sophie primas sénatrice des
yvelines mère d'aubergenville bonsoir
bienvenue secrétaire départemental des
républicains dans le département tout
nouveau poste vous venez d'être nommé à
cette fonction un nouveau duo à la tête
des républicains dans le département
puisque david douillet lui est devenu le
nouveau patron ce nouveau responsable
départemental
il succède à valérie pécresse quel sera
votre priorité
la priorité c'est de profiter de l'élan
qui a été donnée par la campagne des
régionales et particulièrement ici dans
les yvelines sous l'impulsion bien sûr
de valérie pécresse mais aussi de david
douillet qui était tête de liste on va
dire ivy noise et et qui a su générer
dans les yvelines une grande dynamique
de recrutement d'entousiasme de campagne
qui est exactement ce dont on a besoin
pour préparer 2017
parce que david douillet sa priorité
c'est renforcer le travail de terrain
avec les militants concrètement comment
ça va se passer concrètement l'animation
de ce département va se renforcer
nous voyons tous les délégués de
circonscription très très fréquemment
avec un plan d'action avec
ddd réunion avec des plans d'actions de
terrain effectivement et des objectifs
qui sont des objectifs à la fois de
recrutement mais aussi d'animations
j'allais dire intellectuelle du terrain
par l'organisation de débats de
rencontres pour que les républicains
soient vraiment au coeur de la vie des
français et des yvelinois en particulier
comment se porte cette formation au sein
du département des yvelines les
républicains en termes de militants la
page ump aussi a été définitivement
tournée
oui la page du mpc bien tourner
puisqu'en fait jaillir
traditionnellement dans les yvelines et
encore une fois sous l'impulsion de
valérie pécresse on était loin des
conflits loin des divergences on a
toujours un département qui a su
respecter les opinions les uns et des
autres est allé dans une dynamique de
réussite et de doré sites de batailles
électorales et ça nous a plutôt bien
réussi
combien de militants aujourd'hui on part
vous posez une colle dans le département
je n'ai pas les derniers chiffres dont
je vais pas vous dire des bêtises mais
on est en progression
parmi les dossiers qui vont vous
intéresser très rapidement dans les
prochaines semaines c'est cette élection
législative partielle parce que valérie
pécresse maintenant qu'elle est élue
présidente de la région elle a
démissionné tout simplement de ce poste
2e circonscription qui couvre vélizy
versailles une partie de versailles le
candidat de la droite et du centre c'est
pascal thévenot le maire de vélizy a été
officialisée par lui dit le modem et
donc les républicains et hier tout
simplement
aujourd'hui ce candidat de bonnes
chances de l'emporter cette désignation
s'est aussi faite naturellement parce
que ils vendent vannes l'ancien
suppléant de valérie pécresse aurait
bien aimé aussi se présenter oui parce
qu'elle thévenoud et et j'allais dire le
candidat naturel pour nous d'abord c'est
quelqu'un d'extrêmement fidèle et loyal
vis-à-vis de valérie pécresse est
quelqu'un qui a gagné une grosse
bataille sur vélizy qui dirige
évidemment une une ville tout à fait
importante pour le département des
yvelines
et puis c'est quelqu'un qui avait envie
voilà donc je crois que l'envi dans
notre dans notre parti ça compte aussi
beaucoup il a eu le soutien de tous les
maires de droite de sa circonscription
et ce n'est pas rien d'avoir
l'assentiment de tous les élus de
terrain puisque c'est aussi beaucoup eux
qui font une élection est donc c'était
tout à fait quelqu'un de naturel pour
remplacer pour succéder à valérie trépas
port à l'ancien suppléant il
voilà bah ils vendent bada et et
suppliant de valérie pécresse il
aujourd'hui au conseil départemental il
est président d'un parc naturel régional
je crois que le il n'y a pas eu de sujet
en réalité moi je n'ai pas entendu de
sujets sur la succession de valérie
l'élection ce sera 13 et 20 mars
du côté des socialistes le nom n'est pas
encore arrêtée pour le candidat en
revanche pour le front national ce sera
vincent colo s'est d'ores et déjà
entériné je parle du front national
justement l'adversaire aujourd'hui pour
les républicains
c'est le parti socialiste c'est le front
national je pense que l'indiquent mans
dans cette élection même au-delà
aujourd'hui parce que la question se
pose du côté des républicains
pour moi la dois pas cibler un
adversaire en particulier
je crois qu'il faut qu'on arrête de se
positionner par rapport aux autres les
républicains sont les républicains nous
avons un parti nous avons des valeurs
nous sommes en train de travailler sur
des programmes avec des candidats pour
les primaires qui tous se font des
grands livres et quand vous les lisez en
fait vous apercevez cas pas énormément
énormément d'écart dans les
positionnements et notamment sur les
matières économiques
donc c'est un parti qui est au travail
on doit se définir par rapport à ceux
qu'on aime aux valeurs qu'on défend par
rapport aux programmes que nous allons
défendre l'année prochaine et pas
tellement par rapport aux uns et aux
autres la question n'est plus de savoir
si on est tellement au centre totalement
à droite
la question c'est de savoir qui on est
nous voilà je pense que si l'on se pose
les républicains parce qu'il ya des
réunions de préparation aussi sur les
différents différents rendez vous
politique et ça fait par pippa remis par
un pardon partie des différentes
questions qui seront posées est-ce que
l'adversaire c'est le parti socialiste
est ce que c'est le front national comme
on s'adresse aux électeurs
là on parle de cette élection
législative partielle alors c'est pas
tout à fait la même circonscription mais
on reste sur versailles dans les deux
bureaux de vote sur le secteur de satory
qui est un des quartiers de versailles
aux dernières régionales le front
national est arrivé en tête mais je
crois que ce sont des messages qu'il
faut qu'on entende et qu'on essaye de
comprendre les raisons pour lesquelles
une partie de notre électorat et une
partie de l'électorat de gauche
aujourd'hui s'exprime dans un vote
extrême mais encore une fois une fois
qu'on a compris ça il faut qu'on apporte
nos réponses à nous et ses réponses mais
elles doivent être un guide pour nos
électeurs nous ne sommes pas contre
front national ou contre le parti
socialiste nous sommes les républicains
avec un programme
et parfois ça rejoint quelques éléments
de gauche parfois saragosse a rejoint
quelques éléments d'extrême droite mais
c'est parce que nous essayons de trouver
des solutions pour la france qui en a
besoin on va profiter de votre présence
aussi pour vous faire réagir en tant que
sénatrice des yvelines avec ce projet de
révision constitutionnelle qui vous
occupent ainsi que tous les députés les
sénateurs actuellement surtout cette
semaine puisque c'est à l'étude
et quel est votre positionnement là
dessus notamment sur la question de la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
faut-il prolonger ou non déjà alors
foutu pour longer la question était
réglée hier au sénat parce que nous
avons voté à la majorité oui il faut
prolonger puisque il ya effectivement un
état d'urgence qui le nécessitent après
une deuxième question qui utilisa
déchéance de la nationalité
wiki et la prolonge qu'il le la
constitutionnalisation et de la
d'urgence voilà et ensuite la déchéance
de nationalité et tout ça ce sont des
thèmes un petit peu différent pour jouer
d'urgence alors pour le moment je ne
suis pas très convaincu en fait je pense
qu'en fait cet état d'urgence est très
important dans les temps que nous vivons
est en réalité je pense qu'on pas on
pose mal le débat
moi ce qui m'a frappé quand on a voté la
première période de ton d'urgence et de
lendemain du vote on avait des dizaines
et des dizaines de perquisitions qui se
débloquer du jour au lendemain
donc en fait la question que je me pose
c'est est-ce que c'est un problème en
réalité d'état d'urgence ou c'est un
problème de relations et de
fonctionnement entre la justice et la
police est ce que finalement le problème
et pas plus tôt là et est-ce qu'on règle
par une question constitutionnelle une
question qui est plutôt une question
organisationnelle entre la justice et la
police et moi je préférerais que justice
soit dans le coup parce qu'on est dans
un état de droit et on doit défendre un
certain nombre de valeurs individuelles
de liberté individus
elle et je suis un peu inquiète de cette
entrée de l'état d'urgence dans la
constitution et sur la question de la
déchéance de la nationalité ça divise
toutes les familles politiques a pas
d'unanimité dans un camp ou dans l'autre
est exactement ça divise tout les toutes
les familles politiques
écoutez moi je crois que la loi
aujourd'hui permet la déchéance de
nationalité le texte elle qui sort de
l'assemblée nationale ne me convient pas
parce qu'il fait des apatrides et ça je
ne peux pas imaginer qu'un pays comme la
france puisse créer des apatrides donc
et je trouve qu'on fait beaucoup de
bruit sur un problème qui va rien
résoudre
c'est la seconde question que j'allais
vous posez justement est ce que c'est la
vraie réponse cette question de la
déchéance de la nationalité aux
difficultés que l'on peut rencontrer mur
contre le terrorisme bien sûr que non
bien sûr que non
je comprends que certains défendent la
valeur symbolique de cette de cette
mesure
en réalité on n'est pas dans le temps du
symbole on est dans le temps de l'action
et de l'efficacité par rapport à une
menace qui est éminente puisque on a
l'état d'urgence qui la menace du
terrorisme et je pense qu'il faut mieux
légiférer au sénat nous sommes fait une
loi sur le terrorisme à l'initiative du
président philippe bas et je pense que
le gouvernement serait beaucoup plus
inspiré de reprendre ses droits il a
fait repasser à l'assemblée nationale
que de travailler pendant des jours des
jours et des nuits à des polémiques
autour de la révision de la constitution
une dernière question sur l'actualité
nationale votre candidat pour les
primaires ce sont des républicains
puisque ce sera en 2016 que les
militants adhérents vont devoir se
prononcer alors en tant que secrétaire
départemental je voudrais dire d'abord
que je veillerai à la neutralité
évidemment de la campagne je m'assurais
avec david douillet que tous les
candidats vont pouvoir s'exprimer dans
le respect des uns et des autres dans
notre département
moi j'ai choisi depuis longtemps puisque
je m'étais positionner en 80 en 2013
pardon en faillite en faveur de françois
fillon chez pas changé aujourd'hui mon
fusil d'épaulé
mais je respecte tous les autres
candidats et surtout quand il sera
choisi je choisirais de suivre celui qui
sera élu élections 20 novembre et le 6
novembre si le second tour et est
nécessaire toute dernière question cette
fois-ci en début de semaine s'est tenue
le bureau politique des républicains sur
la nomination justement des responsables
départementaux
on a pu lire dans la presse qu henri
guaino était plutôt en colère au moment
de l'annoncé de votre nomination
voilà je pense qu'il était rien au
député des yvelines oui oui bien sûr un
régal des postiers des yvelines je pense
qu'il était un petit peu en colère parce
que on ne l'avait pas consulté ce que
nous aurions probablement dû faire
aujourd'hui tout va mais aujourd'hui
tout va bien on possède pas du tout
contre moi c'était plutôt contrôler
principe qu'on l'ait pas appeler ce que
ce qui peut se comprendre
merci sophie primas sénatrice les
républicains et nouvelle secrétaire
départemental donc du parti merci à vous
dans un instant le maire de magny les
hameaux viendra donc sur le plateau pour
le moment retour sur le rapprochement
des yvelines avec les hauts-de-seine les
deux départements viennent
d'officialiser la mise en place d'un
établissement public conjoint une
première en france qui annonce à plus ou
moins court terme la mise en place de la
fusion explications william l c'est un
premier pas vers rapprochement des
départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine
le 5 février les conseils départementaux
des deux territoires ont voté pour la
création d'un établissement public de
coopération interdépartementale situé à
vélizy villacoublay
une structure qui selon les deux
présidents devraient permettre des
économies
il n'y a personne d'embauché pour cela
ce sont nos services qui conjointement
travaillent ensemble à la fusion
progressive par exemple pour la voirie
nous allons mettre en somme notre parc
d'engins tout de suite c'est à dire que
évidemment les yvelines comme les osten
puis se servir des engins qui
appartiennent aux deux départements
un rapprochement vu d'un mauvais oeil
par le syndicat cgt qui craint une
dégradation des conditions de travail et
d'éventuelles suppressions de postes
bien entendu une autre fusion ne va pas
créer d'emplois mais après il va pas y
avoir de disparition brutale d'emplois
on va tout simplement faire ce qu'on a
déjà commencé à faire mais à une autre
échelle c'est ne pas renouveler les
contrats ne pas renouveler tous les
départs en retraite
terrain etc si on veut pouvoir un jour
faire baisser les impôts il faut qu'il y
ait moins de fonctionnaires également
abordé le rapprochement de la sem92 et
yveline aménagement une fusion des
sociétés mixtes de développement prévu
pour la fin de l'année 2016 qui
nécessitera l'accord des collectivités
territoriales actionnaires un plan qui
s'inscrit dans un éventuel projet de
fusion des deux départements
invité à présent bertrand voyons bonsoir
je maire de magny les hameaux maire
socialiste votre sentiment sur ce
rapprochement des deux départements
hauts-de-seine et département des
yvelines de réaction là dessus il y a
encore quelques mois de ça lorsqu'on
parlait des nouvelles intercommunalités
a créé jeu proposait la création de
l'intercommunalité qui dépasse déborder
le département des yvelines et qui
allait du côté de l'essonne avec le yen
de paris saclay s'était refusée par le
président du conseil départemental et
deuxième réaction c'est que ce projet
qu'ils inventent effet derrière le dos à
la fois des communes des élus comme moi
et aussi surtout des habitants puisque
la personne n'est informé personne n'est
consulté sur ce rapprochement qui juge
la volonté entre deux personnes pourquoi
pas mais en tout cas que tout le monde
en parle c'est un sujet assez important
est ce que le département des yvelines
doit être fusionnée avec le département
des hauts-de-seine pourquoi pas avec un
autre département dans ce cas là et puis
que deviennent les compétences directes
d'un département comme le département
des yvelines
que devient l'aménagement au niveau d'un
département comme le département des
yvelines qui à la fois urbain et rural
que deviennent les services de proximité
dans les domaines de l'action sociale de
la santé qui sont les compétences
directes d'un département
là on voit et puis on le voyait
directement dans le dans le reportage
dont le sujet
le seul souhait est un souhait purement
administratif de réduction de réduction
de l'emploi
sauf que derrière ce qui est oublié
c'est que derrière ces réductions
d'emploi il à des réductions de services
publics et les fonctions même d'un
département c'est un service de public
de services publics de proximité auprès
des habitants le conseil départemental
avec qui vous êtes aussi en conflit sur
ce dossier de centres de protection
maternelle et infantile
il devrait fermer ses portes ce mercredi
10 février est définitivement à la
faveur d'un plan de réorganisation là
aussi et qui touche tout le département
les pmi sont ces centres qui sont gérés
pour par les conseils départementaux en
faveur des femmes enceintes et des
enfants de moins de 6 ans vous l'avez
découvert quand cette fermeture alors
vous êtes plutôt surpris forcément ça
surprend puisque on avait des
discussions entre on a eu une discussion
avec le conseil départemental en juillet
l'année dernière ce n'est le 6 juillet
on avait été convoqué au département à
ce sujet on avait expliqué la complexité
d'une fermeture pour magny les hameaux
du fait de l'éloignement de magny les
hameaux par rapport à d'autres centres
éventuel donc de la complexité pour les
habitants pour pouvoir y aller en
transport en commun plus d'une heure dix
pour venir sur sur
montigny-le-bretonneux avec les
poussettes etc
à un moment donné c'est ça paraît un
petit peu comme un petit peu compliqué
un service à magny les hameaux sur deux
permanences qui sont remplies donc ils
sont vraiment utiles qui répondent à un
vrai besoin
un vrai service de proximité on a eu ces
discussions a priori ça semblait ne plus
être dans la lignée des forts à des
fermetures
on attendait une réponse par écrit que
j'ai demandé début novembre que je
n'avais pas donc je m'inquiétais de tout
ça j'en ai parlé à nos conseillers
départementaux qui a priori avait
demandé des informations au département
mais n'avait pas de retour d'après ce
que je savais début janvier à mes voeux
je me suis interrogé sur ses non
réponses j'ai reçu un courrier le 11
janvier qui me disait que ça allait
fermer sans date sans rien
j'allais demander une réunion avec le
président du conseil départemental pour
pouvoir m'exprimer de nouveau sur ce
sujet a expliqué les raisons de mon
désaccord par rapport à ça 2 et puis
surtout pour trouver les solutions pour
pérenniser ce service de proximité
auprès des habitants surtout par rapport
aux discussions qu'on avait plus à voir
avec les services du département
et puis finalement je m'aperçois parce
que
ça parle dans une commune comme magny
les hameaux et puis on a fini par savoir
que la fermeture doit avoir lieu demain
voilà comme ça c'était vraiment le maire
derrière la vue des images de la tournée
mardi matin de cette mobilisation et
vous avez appris donc cette fermeture
d'un délai assez tard mais la verrière
par exemple guyancourt aussi à une forte
mobilisation des idées parce que parce
que dès le début on leur disait voilà ce
centre fermera de notre côté dans les
discussions qu'on a eues avec cette
collectivité qui est partenaire de la
commune de magny les hameaux
la pmi accueillis dans des locaux de la
ville
dans les discussions il n'y avait pas de
souhaits de fermeture direct de la pmi
et il y avait une volonté que nous on a
compris de discussions avec la ville
pour trouver les moyens de pérenniser va
terminer au temps passant le belize et
tout de suite on va attendre on va
discuter on a on a nous fait le jeu de
la confiance avec le département pour
pouvoir travailler sur un service de
santé pour les familles des enfants
nécessaire et voir toutes les solutions
possibles pour pouvoir pérenniser un
service de proximité
je vous le disais en juillet nous avions
un rendez vous on a également rencontré
des services de département c'était en
octobre qui nous disaient même qu'a
priori il n'y avait pas d'information
sur une fermeture de l'est aujourd'hui
s'est arrêtée mercredi la pmi sera
fermée je ne sais même pas ça c'est ce
qui nous est revenue par les différentes
discussions les différents réseaux que
nous avons il nous a été dit a priori
plus de plus de prise de rendez-vous à
partir du 8 février
et il faut faire l'écart il faut que les
services face à leurs cartons pour le 10
février le 10 février donc demain
dernière permanence
a priori c'est à dire qu'on n'a aucune
information officielle de la part du
département sur quoi que ce soit et même
sur mes demandes de rendez vous auprès
du conseil départemental auprès du
président auquel j'ai associé les deux
conseillers départementaux de mon canton
nous n'avons absolument aucune réponse
et au delà de ça c'est même pas une
question de courrier c'est une question
aussi d'appels téléphoniques pour
trouver les dates pour ce rendez vous il
n'ya aucune réponse rien du tout prix
parce que vous l'avez souligné il y
avait deux élus de votre canton que ce
soit yvan de valve ou alexandra à
rosetti donc pour les républicains et
pour lui dès qu'ils qui se mobilisent
aussi pour obtenir au moins une pmi
mobile parce qu'on sait ce qu'il se dit
dans la presse
il propose d'une soleil aidant la grèce
j'ai découvert un communiqué de presse
des deux conseillers départementaux et
votre présente aussi au conseil
municipal
or berger qui peut-être aussi en tout
cas j'ai découvert ça dans la presse
c'est bien tant mieux de se mobiliser
maintenant ce que je constate
il faut regarder les faits un vote
au conseil départemental en juin l'année
dernière de réduction du nombre de pmi
voté à la très large majorité il y à une
personne qui n'a pas voté cette
délibération c'est monsieur brio tout le
monde à voter donc nos conseillers
départementaux également du canton et
puis le 2 février au moment où nous
lançons la pétition au moment où nous
apprenons justement la fermeture
derrière le dos des habitants en
catimini un petit peu comme si on
déménage et les outils production d'une
usine en pleine nuit pour éviter que le
lendemain les ouvriers travaillent au
moment où on apprend ça je découvre dans
la presse
communiqué de presse de nos conseillers
départementaux qui explique en effet
c'est peut-être pas une bonne solution
de fermer la pmi de magny les hameaux du
fait de l'éloignement géographique où
votre adversaire tel quel aujourd'hui on
va passer mes demandes sont simples la
première c'est que ça ne ferme pas on
est déjà et que la deuxième on discute
c'est à dire que le département discute
avec la ville sur les meilleures
solutions pour pérenniser le service au
niveau des habitants certains évoquent
une unité mobile c'est ce qu'il se
faisait il ya une trentaine d'années à
peu près c'est un véhicule qui va de
ville en ville pour stationner un peu
comme le bibliobus que nous avons à
saint quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui on a des locaux qui sont
disponibles ils sont mis à disposition
du conseil départemental pour deux après
midi par semaine
moi ces locaux il reste à disposition
donc pourquoi prendre ça reste et c'est
autant par cette unité mobile finalement
et qui pourrait permettre même d'aller
dans les locaux qui sont qui sont à
chevreuse pourquoi pas parce qu'ils ont
fermé cette pmi aussi pour pouvoir aller
faire une permanence également et ainsi
de suite
finalement l'unité mobile que ce soit
enfin le véhicule sert pas à grand chose
puisque vous allez l'aimer tout ça tout
ça surtout qu'on en discute qu'on en
discute et qu'on évite d'être
irrespectueux vis-à-vis des élus que
nous sommes et vis-à-vis des habitants
puisque l'objectif l'objet même d'un
département
c'est le service aux habitants dans les
compétences qui sont les siennes
l'action sociale la santé et ils doivent
les maintenir voilà pour le dossier de
la pmi on va juste prendre
minutes avant de conclure cette émission
pour évoquer les rapports avec
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines l'arrivée des nouvelles
communes cinq nouvelles communes qui
s'est concrétisée au 1er janvier vous
l'avez suivi il ya les tensions entre la
gauche entre la droite pour schématiser
un petit peu les choses est notamment
parce que les élus de l'opposition n'ont
pas obtenu de vice-présidence tout
simplement aujourd'hui où en sont les
rapports avec la majorité de 50 leur
niveau c'est pas tout simplement parce
que des élus de l'opposition n'auraient
pas tenu deux vice-présidences les
vice-présidences vous auriez sans doute
siéger c'est pas une question des plus
d'opposition attention établissements
publics de coopération intercommunale
c'est une coopération entre les communes
à partir du moment où des communes ne
peuvent pas travailler complètement et
être aux responsabilités complètement et
notamment travaillé dans l'exécutif et
mettre la main à la pâte en quelque
sorte
dans ce cas là il n'ya plus
d'intercommunalité il n'y a plus de
coopération intercommunale ne s'est pas
uniquement un rapport comme vous le
semble et leur union à gauche droite etc
c'est c'est une question quelle commune
aujourd'hui on droit à travailler avec
l'ensemble des communes et en n'ayant
pas de vie au jour dans un bâtiment de
24 avril une qui n'ont pas
l'autorisation de travailler avec
l'ensemble des communes pour pouvoir
définir ce nouveau projet de territoire
que nous devons mettre en place
puisqu'il faut qu'on apprenne à
travailler à 12
nous avons beaucoup de travail il faut
le faire et simplement aujourd'hui ce
travail ne se fait pas 12
pour moi il se fait à 12 - 4 donc moi
ces quatre communes magny les hameaux
trappe
la verrière et réduits en cours qui ne
siège pas en tout cas en tant que
vice-président la suite justement des
rapports comment ça va continue toujours
je vous la raison ne siégeait pas parce
qu'on ne sait que le maire de la
verrière a fait passer un communiqué où
il expliquait qu'il voulait plus être
présent en tant que maire justement
parce qu'il n'y avait plus de confiance
avec la majorité aujourd'hui je continue
d'appeler à la raison une commune comme
magny les hameaux
je le répète c'est une commune de lien
entre les territoires
c'est une commune qui fait le lien avec
le parc naturel régional de la haute
vallée de chevreuse dont nous faisons
partie
une commune qui fait le lien avec
l'opération d'intérêt national paris
saclay dont nous faisons partie qui fait
le lien avec 50 ans en hiver
dont nous faisons partie si une commune
comme magny les hameaux disait non non
nous l'intercommunalité on n'en veut pas
par rapport à tout le travail qu'on fait
en intercommunalité avec tous nos
voisins
ça serait un comble alors aujourd'hui
vous voulez moi ça soit revue refait en
soirée dansante mère je demande à ce que
l'ensemble des territoires de
l'intercommunalité de la coopération
intercommunale au niveau de saint
quentin en yvelines soit pris en compte
et puisse travailler sereinement avec
tout le monde pour construire ce projet
de territoire qui est l'essentiel parce
que le coeur des choses
encore une fois c'est le service aux
habitants et faut pas l'oublier quelle
que soit la diversité des opinions
politiques de l'eiger presse pour la bo
de l'atsa merci bertrand environ d'être
venu à sur ce plateau maire de magny les
hameaux c'est la fin de ce set 8
politique la semaine prochaine retour du
7-8 société les programmes se
poursuivent sur tv fils